you know there's a big difference
between having a business partner and
having a right hand guy
a number two or a second in command
today we're going to talk about
qualities of a great second in command
history tells us number two can make you
or break you let me explain to what i
mean by this look at obama obama's
number two was biden
did you ever feel that biden wanted the
attention that obama got
never look at trump trump's number two
is what pence do you ever
feel that pence needs the kind of
attention that trump gets not at all
now watch this nixon was number two to
eisenhower
it didn't work out too well because he
hated being number two right it didn't
work out for
eisenhower was a great president
two-term president people loved him
left and the right nixon was a little
bit edgy right look at lyndon johnson he
hated being the vp of john f kennedy
because he thought he was bigger than
him look at wozniak great number two
look at paul allen steve balmer great
number two look at
many other names i can give you that are
great numbers so like a tim cook
a number two is second in command and
the first point i'm gonna give to you
before we get into all the other points
is the following
a number two is very comfortable being
number two has no desire to compete for
number one
doesn't need the attention that number
one gets it's very comfortable
being number one number two very
comfortable i've had people that have
worked with me
where in front of everybody they say all
the right things let me tell you
patrick's the greatest this greatest
that behind closed doors
but i think i could have done it better
i think i could have done this i think i
could have done that that's not a great
number too because behind closed doors
they're undermining in front of
everybody they're building you up
behind closed doors they're undermining
you which my point number two is the
complete opposite which means behind
closed doors
they edify you in front of you with
nobody around
they undermine you let me say this one
more time hear me out
so behind closed doors people come oh
what are you talking about absolutely
not
oh my gosh no i don't know about that i
can't see that happening no
they protect they it's almost annoying
when pence protects trump
it's annoying when biden protects obama
how annoyed does the media get you ever
noticed that
but behind closed doors again great
number two is gonna say you know i think
you kind of want a little too much today
you know i think you meant but there's
nobody around there's not a husband
around there's not a white front there's
not
anybody it's only the two and the four
walls okay
that says you mind if i give you some
feedback yes
i think dot dot dot i i i ca
do i have your permission to kind of
just give you a little bit of feedback
behind closed doors and this person has
to earn the right
to have that kind of a relationship with
the person you don't just all of a
sudden come in acting like you have this
uh
liberty to do something like that it's
very to do that to a number one is a
very different dynamic
this is why number three is great number
twos
are masters of human nature they are
masters of human nature like they
understand
right here this a little sensitive no
i'm going to back up a little bit
hey you know what why don't we just do
this we're going to we're going to
finish the meeting right now
we'll get back to you guys and we'll let
you know what we want to do number two
read that
okay a number two understands human
nature and say you know what
look you want to just go for a walk
let's just go for a walk yeah yeah i
just want to go for a walk
he knows that number one's got a lot on
his mind let's go for a walk yeah
hey you know what let me let me just you
mind if i take you some let's just go
eat something let's just go with
something
if the guy likes to golf you know let's
go with some balls you might have let's
just go ahead some we got two hours
let's go at some balls let's go with
some balls a great number
two has a great sense of human nature
and they
understand what to do and what not to do
here's number four
the reason why they're able to do this
is because a great number two great
second in command
doesn't just buy into the vision of the
leader the bot
into the leader let me say that one more
time it's not like
i remember when wozniak i interviewed
him 11 years ago and we're sitting down
there's like you know 4 500 people in an
audience
and i'm interviewing wozniak he couldn't
say
anything bad about jobs anything he said
you know to be able to do what we did at
apple is you need somebody like job
somebody that's just willing to go up
against everybody and i understood the
role jobs had to play and
you know i i don't think anybody could
have done what jobs did and without him
apple would have never been what it
became
can you imagine at that point he can
easily
spin the story to build himself up but
he put himself
out there to talk about what happened
very comfortable to say
without jobs apple would have never
happened that's a great number two right
there
because not only did he buy into the
vision of what apple came to
where he left his job but he also bought
into the individual
very important that you bought into the
individual
pence bought him to trump not you penn
state you know biden bought into obama
maybe not you
but biden did it worked out not just the
vision obama had not just the vision
trump had
but the individual and that leads me to
point number five
a great number two is not expecting
perfection from uh from their number one
they're not this isn't like oh my gosh
you know what do you think about what
this person did you know i hear that the
number he's got a very bad temper well
you know what there's one thing about
such and such you know he has got high
expectation and he wants us to win
and he's not willing to compromise and
quite frankly i like that that's what
attracted me to wanting to work with him
do you see what just happened right that
whole idea about well you know you know
what do you think about the fact that
he's got such a lose you know he just
can come out and say some curse words
how do you feel about that
well look i understand sometimes it's a
choice of words he uses
but unfortunately the person you only
see is the person on the outside i get
to see this man when it's just he and i
sitting together
having a cup of coffee or having a
conversation together i see a completely
different side
the only thing you see is when he gives
a talk and he slips i see him
all the time and i can tell you this is
a great man and a great leader
do you see how this and by the way
here's here's the thing to understand
either you can do this comfortably or
you can't you can't force it though
i don't know if that made sense let me
let me let me say this to you one more
time
either you can do this comfortably or
you can't
but you cannot force it you can't say i
need you to do this to be a great number
two
no no no i have guys that they could
never
ever do this and that's totally fine
because it's not in their dna
but i got guys that make an incredible
number two
and they're very comfortable being a
flag carrier and it's in their dna
it's simple and when you typically do
that those same people that make great
number twos
guess what eventually ends up happening
to them many times they end up being
number ones who runs apple today
tim cook ends up running apple today did
you see the stock options and the money
he just got recently
have you seen his net worth right now
what happened to him do you know what
steve ballmers wore today
we did my book when i wrote it i said
his net worth words is 56 billion
dollars
you know what he's worth today 72
billion dollars steve ballmer do you
know what happens when you're great
number two
you end up being a number one and when
you become number one it's not through
force i remember there was an insurance
you i was working with
11 years ago when i sat with them i
can't get the name because it's a very
big name but when i sat with them
i don't know if i've met many people
that are as good as this guy was
absolute ridiculously a genius
a driver a worker everything
he only had one problem here's the only
thing that he had one problem
when he was coming up and he really
wanted to be the ceo of this massive
company this company is a
it's a 200 billion outcome it's a
massive company he wanted to be a ceo of
this 200 billion dollar company
every single time i had dinner with him
while we were together
he couldn't help but take a shot at the
current ceo
he couldn't help do it every single time
he would do it and i
was like oh my gosh he's like
overwhelming and at the time this is
i'm 30 years old at the time when he's
doing this and he was in his mid 50s you
know maybe late 50s
and he would do this every time and he
was so ambitious
that he couldn't even control his
ambitions so when it came down to it
when it was time to replace that he did
his job everything and he had been there
for
a good decade he got the job done and
they had to replace him
nobody voted him to be it even though he
he could have qualified to be a ceo
but he was not necessarily the best at
being a great number two
so people were worried if they make a
monsieur it's going to be so much about
him
that the decisions he may make may only
be the kind of decision that's going to
benefit who
him see sometimes not being a good
number two scares the hell out of people
who want to make you number one
because if you can't take the kind of
recognition that comes with number two
what makes anybody think that you can
handle the kind of recognition that
comes with you being number one
so you got to kind of be thinking about
all of those concepts but again
a person cannot force you to be
a great number two you either can be a
great number two you can't be number two
right here's the next one
the other thing is all of these things i
talked about is a lot of human nature
but you have to be very competent with
the business so if you're not competent
with the business there's no such thing
as being a
number two the number two i have right
now the office that i work with
you know who's been with me here for a
few years you know how he works
he gets the job done he goes does things
he works on the weekends he does things
without people telling him what to do
boom boom boom he gets all of that stuff
done
on his own and he's a great number two
he protects he hires he fires he does
all that stuff
and is quiet to himself but you know
what he's got going on for himself
highly highly competent and he's no
attention
he makes very good money he's gonna get
great checks he's going to get great
exits all that stuff he's done very well
for himself
you know why though he's very competent
he knows
what he's doing in his area of expertise
he's a here i'm a hero in his area of
expertise
and never brags about it he just goes
about his business and does it so
a great number to us to also be very
very competent at what they're doing
you got to be reliable and and what i
mean by reliable this kind of goes for
my next point reliability means
accessibility
a number one's got to be able to get a
hold of you anytime i know a lot of
people oh my gosh who would want to have
something like that i
understand that's why not everybody
wants to be a number two a number one
should be able to get a hold of you at
midnight
oh my gosh what kind of a pressure type
of a video is this
are you kidding me yes i'm that serious
i'm not kidding you that's exactly
what's gonna happen with you being a
great number two
pence has got to pick up the call when
trump calls him wozniak's got to pick up
the call when jobs calls him
when jobs call them all of these things
is part of being a great number two
because it's essentially
if that person dies you're number one so
you're pretty much you're one person
away from being number one
i don't this makes sense you're one
person away from being number one you're
pretty much number one
and you are pretty much number one the
only difference between you and number
two is
your number one is that if anything goes
wrong with the company all the pressure
goes to number one not you
so the night day to day all the pressure
they point the finger at number one they
point the finger at number one they
point the finger on number one
when's the last time you saw people
finding fingers at pens everybody points
fingers at trump
when's the last time you saw when a
biden was a pr vice president how many
times did they point fingers are biting
it goes all to obama that's one of the
reasons why two has got to be accessible
because sometimes number one's gotta
bounce some ideas
off number two so now when it comes down
to bouncing ideas off number two this
goes to my next point
a great number two is also very good
because sometimes the number one's gonna
say hey can i talk to you so here's what
i'm thinking i'm struggling with
something right now what are you
struggling with i'm struggling with uh
what just happened right now
in the challenges that's going on
between turkey
and azerbaijan and armenia and russia
and here we have armenia
3 million people azerbaijan 10 million
people turkey's 80 million people but
turkey's an ally because we got three
military bases
but you know senate and house passed the
armenian genocide in u.s and the only
one that hasn't is myself
what do we do in a situation like this i
got
a decent relationship with russia a
decent relationship with turkey
i don't have any what do we do here well
have you thought about doing this
what do you think about this so great
number two is very good at being there
having conversations and asking
questions
not statements asking questions that's
leading number one
down to a potential possibility of what
we need to do today
and maybe what we don't need to do today
we got to wait for this one to happen
six months from that post election these
are some of the things
that a great number two does with a
number one so we talk about a lot of
different things obviously loyalty's got
to be their complaint
protective on number one this next part
is very important meaning you always got
to protect number one
but you have to win the uh the team as
well what do i mean by that so here's
number one
here's number two then there's the team
right you have to protect
number one but at the same time the team
has to have been bought into protect
like
man i got listen i can't believe what he
just said right there guys i understand
he's expecting us to work but remember
he has more pressure than
all of us do right now he's got way i
promise he's got more pressure than we
do and you don't think he wants us to go
out there and win
you don't think you talk about the ceo
you talk about jobs you talk about
you know upgates you're talking about
whoever it is you're protecting that
but at the same time you want the team
guys we can do this
let's come together and prove to him
that we're a great team we can pull this
off
versus yeah i know man oh he's so
difficult believe me i'm around him all
the time and he's under pain in the ass
you show small little marks where you're
not protecting number one
a great number two is protecting it's
protecting
it's protecting but at the same time
he's winning the team over
this is why eventually in number two
when he's winning the team over one he
wants to be a number one
the team wants him to be a number one i
don't know if that made sense let me say
that one more time
if you protect number two and you've won
the team over when it comes time for you
to be number one
you've won this person over and you want
these guys over
they respect him he respects you the
team respects him
you're bound to be the next number one
do you see how that works out but you
got to figure out a way to set aside
ambitions for that to be taking place
a couple other things to share with you
guys when i'm going through this is
an element of urgency meaning when
things are happening and you got to be
willing to go like this
on things that needs to get done hey i
need this no problem let me get it done
for you there's got to be a level of
urgency with number two you don't wait a
week oh i'll get it back to you
a week later five days later three days
later no no what is a unique one let me
get it for you
a great number two let me get a free oh
you know i just talked i got three
people that are doing a deal right now
they're gonna give me three offers i'll
let you know which one we're gonna go
with
and you tell me which one you want to do
okay great okay i have three i got three
deals for you what is it
first one's gonna cost us a million
bucks but it's papa papa pros and cons
the other one's gonna cost the 750 pros
and cons
the other one's going to cost us 500 000
but back in there with another 500 000
but you don't need to pay it back to
them over and over
next four years pros and cons which one
do we want to do well let's go with this
one
great what do you think i think we got
to go with this one so there's got to be
an element of high urgency when you're
dealing
with a number one because a number one
is expecting answers quickly and a great
number two is very good at getting that
for them
very very quickly so having said this
again i share this with you may want to
share this with your number two or
somebody that you think can be a number
two
or second in command here's cheryl with
them and if you are a second in command
and you're very comfortable being second
in command
this may not be a bad video for you to
share with your number one and if you've
watched us saying well pat you said
business partners very difference
between being a
right-hand person or second-in-command
there is because you can have a
son and a father that owns 50 50 of a
company because the father is just an
investor he's out
but the son needs to go find a
right-hand person and it may be a nephew
or a cousin that comes working for him
that becomes his right hand guy father
is just a
business partner or an investor in the
company so if you may be watching and
say well pat
how do i go about running with a family
business how do you make a family
business work
it's a completely different video i did
four and a half years ago that if you've
never watched
it's a must-watch especially if you run
a family business
click over you to watch it and if you've
not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
you